قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو ان معركه توحيد القدس لا تزال
مستمره اضاف نتنياهو في اجتماع عقدته
حكومته بنفق اسفل الحائط البراق بالمسجد
الاقصى ان توحيد القدس يحتم استمرار
حكومته بتركيبها الحاليه ياتي هذا بعد
اقتحام وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
باحات الاقصى وهو ما قبل بموجه تمديدا
وتحذيرات فلسطينيه وعربيه واسلاميه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما فحوى تصريحات
نتنياهو بشان القدس في اجتماع حكومته تحت
حائط البراق وما دلاله اختيار هذا المكان
لاجتماع الحكومه وتزامن ذلك مع اقتحام احد
اعضائها باحات الاقصى على اي النحو يمكن
ان نقرا ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه والعربيه
والاسلاميه على تصعيد حكومه اليمين
الاسرائيلي المتطرف اعتداءاتها الممنهجه
ضد القدس والمسجد الاقصى وما بدا وجاهد
التحذيرات من ان تؤدي الاستفزازات
الاسرائيليه الى تفجر الاوضاع في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وجر المنطقه الى موجه جديده من
المواجهات
[موسيقى]
داخل نفق اسفل الحائط الغربي للمسجد
الاقصى المعروف باسم حائط البراق عقدت
حكومه اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل اجتماعها
الاسبوعي احتفاء بذكرى احتلال القدس
الشرقيه التي قال نتنياهو ان مهمه تحريرها
لم تكتمل وانا معركه توحيدها لا تزال
مستمره اضاف نتنياهو امام اجتماع الحكومه
الذي صادق على اضافه نحو 17 مليون دولار
لميزانيه حفر الانفاق تحت حائط البراق
والبلده القديمه ان استمرار حكومته
بتركيبتها الحاليه ضروري من اجل امن
اسرائيل ووحده القدس بحسب تعبيره
ساعات قبل اجتماع الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اقدم وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي لتامار
بن جزير للمره الثانيه بعد تعيينه في هذا
المنصب على اقتحام المسجد الاقصى المبارك
تحت حراسه امنيه مشدده
ووصفير المسجد الاقصى الذي اشار اليه باسم
جبل الهيكل بانه روح الشعب اليهودي واكد
انه سيبقى تحت السياده الاسرائيليه الى
الابد حسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من القدس
خليل التفكجي الخبير في الشؤون في شؤون
الاستيطان معنا من الناصره وديعه واوده
الخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي ومن واشنطن
ضيفنا هو المحلل الاستراتيجي في الحزب
الديمقراطي الامريكي ومستشار شؤون الامن
القومي الامريكي السابق مرحبا بكم جميعا
سنبدا معك سيد وديع عواوده من الناصره
والدلالات من وراء ما حدث اليوم هذا
الاجتماع للحكومه الاسرائيليه في نفق تحت
المسجد الاقصى وقبل ذلك الاقتحام الثاني
للوزير تمار بن جزير كوزير في هذه الحكومه
مدلالات كل ذلك
نعم اولا بنك فير كما هو الحال منذ بدايه
هذا الائتلاف منذ ان انطلاق يحاول ان يكسب
النقاط من خلال وسائل الاعلام ومتديات
التواصل الاجتماعي ولذلك صار رئيس
المعارضه لوصفه بوزير التيك توك وهو كان
قد وصل على جناحي هذا التحريض وهذا
الاعتداء وهذا التحرش وهذا الاستفزاز وصل
الى كرسي الوزاره وبما يتعلق بما هو اخطر
هو موضوع اجتماع الحكومه الاسرائيليه في
هذا النفق هناك دلاله طبعا كما قلت اختي
الكريمه بموضوع المكان والزمان هذه
الجلسه الان اختيرت هنا في المكان وفي
الزمان ولها دلالات متعدده الاتجاهات اولا
على المستوى العام ينبغي ان نؤكد ذلك
ونوضح بشكل قاطع
نتنياهو عمل على تكريس احتلال القدس وجمع
شطري المدينه المحتله منذ ان خرج الى عالم
السياسه ومنذ ان ترى راس الحكومه الاولى
في وتسعين الكنبين الحمله الدعائيه
السياسيه التي اطلقها في العام 96 مقابل
شبعون بيرس وهو مرشح حزب العمل كانت
وبنصيحه
مستشار اعلامي امريكي بيريز يقسم او يشطر
مدينه القدس وعمل نتانيا منذ تلك الفتره
على منع ان تكون هناك اي تسويه وخاصه في
مدينه القدس وهذا ما ياتي ايضا في كتابه
مكان تحت الشمس وكان والده قبل ان يرحل
يعني قبل سنوات قد قال للقناه الثانيه
عشره في تعقيبا على تصريحات ادنى بها
نتنياهو في السابق بانه يعيد تسويه دولتين
عشيه زياره براكوم اوباما الرئيس الامريكي
السابق
خطاب الشهير في القاهره كان والدا تنوكل
نعم كان قد قال ان نتنياهو ابني ويتحدث عن
ابنه يطلق مثل التصريحات للاعلام فقط ولكن
بقرار نفسه وانا اعرف ابني جيدا لا يريد
ان يتنازل عن حجر واحد في ارض اسرائيل
ويتحدث عن فلسطين طبعا الان هذه الرساله
هي جزء من التوجهات الاستراتيجيه بما
يتعلق بالتوقيت الان هذه الرسائل داخليه
تندرج ضمن الحسابات والسجلات الداخليه لان
هناك من يهدد داخل حكومته هناك حزبان حزب
القوي اليهوديه وحزب ديجل تراب بعدم
التصويت على موازنه الدوله العامه بعد
يومين وعدم المصادقه على الموازنه العامه
في اسرائيل يعني سقوط الحكومه ولذلك
نتنياهو اراد ان يكون لهذه الحكومات
تعالوا لنكمل هذه الطريق طريق ان نحول دون
تقسيم القدس ان هناك في اسرائيل مسؤولين
اسرائيليين ايضا يخططون لتسويه ومستعدون
لتشاطر القدس وهو بذلك ايضا اراد ان يكسب
النقاط امام الجهاد الاسلامي طيب بعدما ان
كانت هناك شكوك كثيره في اسرائيل ايضا لان
قوه الردع لم تسترجع مقابل الجهاد
الاسلامي رغم رغم اختلال موازان موازين
هذا الكم الهائل من الدمار
بالقرارات الصادره عن اجتماع هذه الحكومه
حديث عن زياده موازنه حفر الانفاق في اسفل
المسجد الاقصى وعن ايضا تشجيع الشبان
اليهود للعيش في القدس كيف يمكن تقييم ذلك
السياسه اسرائيليه واضحه تماما بعمليه
الدمج ما بين القدس الغربيه والشرقيه ان
القدس هي القلب للشعب اليهودي ان هذه
الانفاق اننا سنسيطر على ما فوق الارض
بالاستيطان وما تحت الارض بالانفاق
وبالتالي العمليه زياده الانفال الانفاق
او زياده
الصرف بالنسبه للجانب الاسرائيلي بهذه
الحكومه اليمينيه وانا اعتقد انه لا يوجد
فرق ما بين بيريس وما بين نتنياهو وما بين
الاحزاب خاصه في داخل مدينه القدس الانفاق
هي موجوده جزء منها موجود موجود لم نعرفه
وبالتالي هو ان يريد ان يصلوا الى مرحله
نقول بها اننا وجدنا تاريخ لنا لانه اليوم
كانت رساله نتنياهو واضحه تماما هذه
الرساله الى ابو مازن هذه الرساله الى
الاردن اننا نحن تاريخنا قبل ثلاثه الاف
عام وبالتالي هو ان ذهب الى ما تحت الارض
حتى يوجد اننا كنا قبل المسلمين والعرب في
هذه البلاد حقيقه ما يوجد الان في النفق
هي دلاله واضحه لانه كما معروف انه عندما
فتح النفق في فتره شارون في تلك الفتره
سنه 1996 كانت انتفاضه النفق وبالتالي
اليوم هو تاكيد مره اخرى لكل الرساله
الواضحه تماما للاردن ان الاردن رساله
واضحه نحن اسياد المنطقه الحرم ويقصد هنا
كما ذكرت بن جفير جبل الهيكل ايضا ما تحت
الارض هو لنا وبالتالي انتم عندما تتكلمون
عن عمليه القدس القدس هي لنا القدس شرقها
وغربها لنا القدس بمفهومها لا يتم دمجها
ولا يمكن فصلها مره اخرى وبالتالي كان
اليوم هذا رساله واضحه لكل العالم العربي
والاسلامي انكم لا تتكلمون عن هذا الموضوع
تكلموا عن الحوض المقدس الحوض المقدس الذي
يتكلم عنه اللي هو مساحه تقريبا اتنين نص
كيلو متر هناك كان اجدادنا هنا المسيح
المنتظر سياتي من السماء حامل الهيكل هذه
قبور الانبياء وبالتالي هنا سنقيم هذا
الهيكل اذا كانت هي تحويل كل السياسه بثوب
ديني للوصول للهدف الاستراتيجي الواضح
تماما ان القدس غير قابله للتقسيم طيب باي
عين تراقب الولايات المتحده هذا التطور
اليوم
الحقيقه اداره باردا
مشغوله في
اجتماع
مجموعه سبعه
[موسيقى]
وهو يراقب ما يجري في الشرق الاوسط
ودعني اقول ان عندما ذكرتهم بنياهو
هذا النوع من التصرفات التي قام بها خلال
حياته السياسيه
تسبب التوتر
والغضب
وعندما يتحدث عن
تحرير القدس
هو ما يهمه هو تحرير الاسرائيليين
ولا يرى حضورا للفلسطينيين
وهذا غير سوي
هي دائره من الاعمال المثيره للتوتر مره
بعد اخرى وهناك عمل كهذا ثم ما سيحدث انا
الفلسطينيين
واخرين سوف يردون الفعل على ذلك ثم اذا هو
اخذ ورد واخذ ورد وهذا مثير للاحباط
الوزير بلينكل يحاول ان يوجد نوعا من
الوضع السلمي ولكن نتني
وحكومته اليمينيه غير معنيه وغير مهتمه
بالسلام بل هو مهتم بشيء ليس لديه الا حل
لاسرائيل وحدها وفي هذه
البيئه لن يكون ذلك ممكنا وكيف تقرا
الاداره الامريكيه هذه الرساله كما ذكرت
هو يعني يرسل رساله بان الحل هو لاسرائيل
وحدها كيف يمكن ان تتعامل الاداره
الامريكيه مع هكذا رساله
[موسيقى]
ويحاول ان يجد كونه ينبغي ان يكون هناك حل
سلمي وان هذا التصرفات التي تسرع على
التوتر لا ينبغي ان
نقبلها ينبغي ان نراقبها عن كثب لكن هناك
الكثير من النقاشات
اعود اليك سيد وديع نتنياهو يتحدث في
تصريحاته عن معركه لتوحيد القدس ويقول
انها معركه مستمره في ظل هذا الائتلاف
اليوم وفي ظل هذه الحكومه ما شكل هذه
المعركه المعركه باعتقادك ما الشكل الذي
تتخذه
نعم هذه هو فرصه ربما مناسبه للتاكيد
وربما هو المؤكد ولكن لا باس من ذلك ان
نتنياهو لم يوجه هذا الخطاب او هذه
الرساله للعرب والمسلمين وللعالم بقدر ما
هي بالاساس رساله داخليه للاسرائيليين وهي
رسائل الاحتياجات الداخليه لماذا اقول ذلك
لم نشهد قمه عربيه ولا اسلاميه ولم نشهد
اي رد فعل فلسطيني او عربه او اسلامي ولا
حتى دوله حتى يعني يطالب اسرائيل
بالانسحاب من الشطر الشرقي للقدس حتى يقوم
نتنياهوه بالتاكيد مره واكاد ان يخرج عن
طوره اليوم هو يقول ان المعركه مفتوحه اما
بشان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهذا
يعني
ربما
النتيجه ستقع على العرب وعلى المسلمين في
القصور وبالتالي من هذا المنطلق انا اسالك
باعتقادك كيف او ما هو شكل الذي ستتخذه
هذه المعركه التي يتحدث عنها
نعم لذلك انا اقول ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه نقلت سفرتها من تل ابيبها القدس
ونتنياهو لا يكترث لا بالضغوط الدوليه ولا
الامريكيه وكلها بمثابه حتى الان ضربائب
شفويه لم تتعرض اسرائيل الى فعل حقيقه على
الارض يردعها من المضيفه انتهاك القانون
الدولي وكل القرارات الامويه لا في القدس
ولا خارج القدس وكذلك ويرعى الحاله
العربيه والاسلاميه المهلهله لذلك انا
اقول حينما يقول هو المعركه مفتوحه تقديري
انه يشير بذلك الى يهدد هو يحاول ان يمسك
هذا الائتلاف الحاكم بالترغيب والترغيب
ويكون لهم ان هناك اوساطا اسرائيليه في
المعارضه مستعده لتقسيم القدس لانها
مستعده بشكل او باخر لتسويه قريبه من
تسويه الدولتين ولذلك دعونا نكمل هذه
المسيره دعوكم من التهديدات بحل الحكومه
دعوكم من المطالبه بالكثير من الامور التي
لا يمكن تحقيقها وانا اتحدث عن الميزانيه
واتحدث عن المطالبات بميزانيات اضافيه
خاصه واما قبل قليل ان المصادقه على
الموازنه العامه بعد يومين هي بمثابه
تصويت على على الحكومه تصويت ثقه بمعنى
اذا فشل هذا الائتلاف بتمرير الميزانيه
هذا يعني فورا ان الحكومه ستسقط ولذلك انا
اعتقد ان الدوافع الحقيقيه معظم الدوافع
بالاضافه الى كون نتنياهو يميني ومتجدد
ويكرر يؤكد
المعركه كما سالتك معي سيد
عواوده سيد وديع من الاردن والسعوديه ومصر
وقطر وتركيا ودول اخرى توالت التدديدات
العربيه والاسلاميه باقتحام وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي ايتامار بن جير المسجد
الاقصى والتحذيرات من مغبه استمرار هذه
التصرفات سبقتها عاصفه من ردود الفعل
الفلسطيني على عمليه الاقتحام فقد وصفت
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه الاقتحام بان اعتداء
سافر له تداعيات خطيره وان محاولات
لن تغير الوضع القائم بالم الاقصى وهي
مرفوضه وستفشل من جانبها حملت الحركه
حكومه الاحتلال مسؤوليه ما سمتها
الاقتحامات الهمجيه لوزرائها والمستوطنين
كما وصفت الحركه انعقاد اجتماع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اسفل الحرم القدسي بانه تصعيد
خطير للحرب الدينيه التي يشنها الاحتلال
على القدس وفق قولها اما حركه فتح فقد
قالت ان عقد حكومه الاحتلال اجتماعها تحت
حائط البراق لن يغير الحقيقه التاريخيه
والدينيه للقدس سيد خليل التفكجي من جهه
لدينا حركه حماس تعتبر ما يحصل
تصعيدا خطيرا للحرب الدينيه وفق ما ورد في
بيانها ومن جهه اخرى يتحدث نتنياهو عن
الحرب المستمره لتوحيد القدس ما هو هذا
المشهد الذي نحن امامه
يعني الحرب التي نقودها بالقدس او يقودها
الجانب الاسرائيلي بقدش هي الحرب
الديموغرافيه بمعنى ان اخر الاحصائيات
التي ظهرت
قبل قبل فتره قصيره بان عدد السكان العرب
من الاجمالي 40% مع ان الجانب الاسرائيلي
وضع سياسه اسرائيليه واضحه عام 1973 ان
العرب 25% من العرب والباقي يهود اذا
المعركه التي سيقودها الان في داخل القدس
هي معركه ديموغرافيه بامتياز لان المعركه
الجغرافيه قد انتهينا منها لانه الجانب
الاسرائيلي يسيطر على 87% من مساحه القدس
التي تم توسيعها بعد عام 1967 اليوم في
داخل مدينه القدس 40 الف اسراء عفوا 40%
من الاسرائيليين بحدود سكان القدس داخل
القدس التي احتلت بالسبعه وستين هنالك 15
مستعمره اسرائيليه
اذا المعركه التي يخوضها الان نتيجه
للدراسات والابحاث هي معركه دوموغرافيه
بامتزاز بمعنى عمليه طرد سكان واحلال
اسرائيليين هذا ما يجري كيف يتم ذلك هي
عمليه دينيه بامتياز لانه اذا حول هذه
المعركه من معركه ما بين مستعمر ومستعمر
الى معركه دينيه سنكون كنحن كاسلمين قد
خسرنا هذه المعركه لانه هذه المعركه ليست
هي بين يهود ومسلمين بمقدار ما هي بين
احتلال اسرائيلي لاراضي وايضا ضد قرارات
الامم المتحده سواء كانت اثنين اربعه
اثنين او ثلاثه ثلاثه ثمانيه وغير ذلك من
القرارات الصادره وبالتالي نحن الان في
هذه المعركه التي نخوضها الاول الذي يريد
ان ياخذها الجانب الاسرائيلي هو تحويلها
الى مسار ديني هنالك الصهيونيه المسيحيه
بالعالم
ما خيارات الفلسطينيين في هذه المعركه
استمعت الى ردود الفعل العربيه والاسلاميه
على ما يحدث هل يمكن الركون الى كل ذلك ما
الخيارات
اولا انسيك من قضيه الادانات والاستنكارات
والشجب وكل ما يتعلق بهذا الامور
الضعيف هو هو هذا الذي يجلب ويدين حقيقه
نحن كم اهل القدس للموجودين في داخل
المدينه استطعنا ان نقود معركه لوحدنا في
قضيه البوابات في عام 2017 وقضيه باب
الرحمه وقضيه باب العمود لكن هذه تحتاج
الى دراسه تحتاج الى اموال تحتاج الى دعم
معنوي لانه راس السهم اليوم الموجود هم
اهل القدس على ذلك الادانه تدينه وتستنكر
وتطهير البرقيات وغير ذلك والتهاب الى
المحاكم الدوليه هذا لا ينفع الذي ينفع
الان الخيار واضح تماما هو دعم اهل مدينه
القدس بشكل كامل سواء كان باقتصادي بشكل
المشافي بدعم كل هذه القطاعات الموجوده في
داخل هذه المدينه
في حلق الجانب الاسرائيلي
استمعت الى ما قاله ضيوفنا الاداره
الامريكيه تعتمد وسائل تقليديه ربما او
تصريحات في التعامل مع هذه المساله وكما
ذكر ضيفنا نتنياهو لا يكترث بكل ذلك هو
ماض في هذه السياسه والاداره الامريكيه
اصلا نقلت سفرتها الى القدس وابقتها هناك
في ظل هذه الاداره وهي تطلق الوعود ولكنها
لا تنفذ الشيء هل يمكن التعامل مع ما يحصل
بهذه الذهنيه وبهذه الادوات التقليديه
[موسيقى]
نقل السفاره حدث في عهد الاداره الماضيه
وهناك جدل
وذلك ما قامت به اداره ترامب بعملها هذاك
لكن من الواضح كما قال الضيف هذه حرب
ديموغرافيه او سكانيه
ونتنياهو
في الاساس منذ سنوات
اوضح انه علينا ان نقوم بالاحتلال عبر
بناء المستوطنات وتوفير المنازل والمساكن
للاسرائيليين
وحرمان الاخرين منها هنا
السلطه الفلسطينيه تحتاجه الى ان تعمل هي
ايضا على ان تحظى بدعم اقليمي ليس من
مقاربه
ارهابيه او
منطقه القوه ولكن هي ما هي سياسه من الذي
سيكون قادرا على العيش هناك ومن لا هذا
شيء من الناحيه
مواجهه بين سكان المدينه والاحتلال
المفروض عليهم اشكر الجزيل الشكر
المحلل الاستراتيجي في الحزب الديمقراطي
الامريكي ومستشار وشؤون الامن القوميه
الامريكيه السابق وشكرا
لضيفين من القدس خليل التفجي الخبير في
شؤون الاستيطان ومن الناصره وديعه واوداء
الخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]